hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to bad dream rich now this
is the final part in the sixth part bad
dream series and because it's called
bridge I really do think that this might
connect the other stories or maybe not
they've all been little itty bitty clue
related but they haven't been anything
else related but either way turn down
your lights turn up your headphones and
parco up cuz it's gonna be wild and
crazy okay so this one's different in
that there's an actual inventory button
here I just noticed
so I probably need to be a little more
info yeah take that you bastard how dare
you be alive and probably care for your
children okay press our mouse or I to
open inventory thank you is that a
reminder from death okay damn it I keep
doing this
I keep ruining everything I come across
so anyway I got one penny good so for
this one I might actually have to
interact with things in the environment
by taking him out of my inventory which
means don't look at me accusatory with
your dead eyes I don't much appreciate
it I've done a lot to stab out my own
eyes got another penny I got two coins
in a magnifier no nowhere I got a mag
crowbar can I have that crowbar you're
never doing this I collapse oh no you
got rejected for a passport old man I
don't think that's how passports worked
did you be around me when I'm in a rage
wait I can't go back oh no I can't go
back what if I missed something I don't
know if I missed anything did I miss
another coin is something fishing okay
how dare you swim in that River and try
to get away from my punishment how dare
you I am a rampaging bridge monster okay
oh I don't know what that is this was it
No aah okay so a little weird little
bizarre little strange what why what why
did I do that
well Oh smoke me it's fun
oh I'm just an impressionable young kid
don't smoke it's bad so he was drunk
driven and he just so happened to crash
which is bad
oh I see the script I see the skid marks
now okay that doesn't make any sense
there's got to be something else to this
but I don't know what it is why is this
a thing all right whatever continuing
forward beer you want some beer buddy
Oh got another coin
cool why do I need these coins for what
purpose am i doing okay
[Music]
hi am i dead or no no no not in my house
oh man
Oh several bites lost few fingers oh I'm
back in the hospital
okay I'm back in the hospital okay I
don't like this
Oh meat good that looks like good tasty
meat I'm so glad that hey can you have
give me some meat I need em some meat
man this is gonna be the bizarre thing
where I am all of the characters all at
once
I'm everyone and no one
okay so there's slightly different pills
eat me eat me with my gross disgusting
mouth chop those pills like you're
supposed to like a weird hmm okay so
that's a room I started in there's a
reception area where there was were a
nurse okay whoa Oh who's all supposed to
happen
wait was everything on the bridge like a
red herring I was not supposed to pick
up all those coins was it like leading
me to believe that something else oh hey
hey hey
all right cool oh wait five see the
problem two plus two equals three be
smart examine your eyes now
this is bizarre I didn't do it it wasn't
me
it warned me I who was someone else it
was a guy with no legs not me okay and
no arms and this sad girl in the
wheelchair so sad oh good - I've almost
there
great oh man okay
so elevator stairs it's gotta be
something else that I'm missing okay do
I have scissors maybe no not for you
okay okay here's a new place you are
sick hey how dare you tell me that I
will drink me oh why was that a thing
why did the scissors need to do that but
I don't care I got a key okay so the for
the first time I have a key ah get out
of there okay so now I have a key sorry
I just had knocked it over because I'm a
reckless maniac but I have a key so I
can open something right right right
what do i unlock oh there was another
area over here okay so there's a
telephone going off at any other side I
can't do that is will urine stain right
there that's delightful very touching
very good okay so there's got to be some
door here that's okay in here where's my
crayons where's my Kranz okay so have
three coins now a number and schizos now
oh hey how's it going did you get help
oh you got help oh my turn is coming up
good I'm so glad you want some scanners
you want to be scattered at least you
got bandages for you that's number seven
is it like every time I know I have to
like do something do I have to do
something all the way up to number 85
that would be a little ridiculous baby
okay even I have coins so I can probably
do something with the coin how about
this oh no no screw you fine I'll just
I'll be back oh here we go you yes I
want that oh good Oh looks so good
oh oh wait I have fingers now can I get
the doctor to reattach them one my
number comes up
it's not something that I can do that's
don't think I can do lady
lunch lady ants for me why aren't you
answering me why okay so this means
something here my number oh hey that guy
got help I think I don't know what
number that is
I don't know my eyes aren't ready my
eyes are bad I can't tell okay so
there's got to be like things that are
changing here and there that I can
access so I have fingers anyone missing
some fingers besides me no okay I'll
just be on my way then
oh hey hey hey hey excuse you what what
what what what yes can you buy me
something to drink I ran out of change
you're very thirsty I I would I would
but uh I don't have any oh no no oh no
no don't do that you want a finger you
can squeeze some juice out of that thing
but no no no oh okay all right
so I need to find the drink the drink II
drink you wanna drink this it looks
nutritious how about from the mop bucket
okay no fine then I need to find a way
to get coins again
lunch lady can you give me some goddamn
coins coz I need some goddamn coins you
need to buy this little girl a drink cuz
she's probably totally normal and not
demonic like everyone else here one ooh
what I get what I get well I got a pen
what is a pen do I don't know what the
pen is for I thought I could get that I
thought that moused over them like way
long oh hey this doors open oh you've
gotta help good good good good I don't
know if that's good coin I need that
yeah I need it more than you right now
on the teddy bear over there is fine at
all and you are doing lovely but I need
to get this little girl coin cuz she's
probably real always a button bag enough
whatever hey I got a button again it
didn't work for some reason
what happened there you go oh I did good
I get it good this this particular game
is way more involved than the other ones
already oh you're not gonna give me
anything where's my reward little girl
where's my reward Do You Know Who I am
okay fine let's be on my way then
whatever oh you're oh no there's my old
room okay so okay so there was nothing
else in here where's my number nineteen
oh good almost there okay so someone
else someone else got help that means
someone else went back to the Oh God
oh this is good this goes in going
blazingly fast okay so someone else yes
you that's weird
okay why is that a thing you want some
schizos you want to be penned in the eye
you want some schizos you want some
fingers how about a number 85 no okay
fine then placebo always believe did I
get that did I take those did I take the
placebo there's nothing you yo okay
gotta gotta gotta gotta got it okay in
here in here it's gotta be something
else in here it's gotta be something
there's gotta be yes what is that what
is it I got glue great I love glue why
don't I get glue what do I need glue I
don't know I need glue but I got glue
glues good I got something that means I
can progress a little bit you want some
glue here don't Huff glue that's bad
you want some glue glue you want glue
you want to be glued I don't know why
any glue I got glue and I got excited
but I don't know why I need it
there's also the poison container there
that's cool
Oh 8700 know my number no clue glue it
up ah damn it oh no no no no no oh okay
hello hi show me your hand okay oh hey
all right nursing nurse EPS SOT doc
maybe Emma knew okay here you go
okay glue ah fingers thank you thank you
so much thank you nurse now shut up and
go away references okay bye okay
are your gone now okay all right sock
squawk oh it's upside-down wait no it's
backwards
wait pan I got this I think this means
anything okay so now that I got a worm I
can get the fish oh oh hey you want some
eyeballs I got some eyes Boop oh you're
happy now right skitters No
can I have something else what is this
key good great key okay so there's
probably another lock thing why did I do
that
why did I did why did I do that I didn't
mean to put that ribbon oh come on I
don't have any more glue okay put that
bacon okay I just need to not touch him
that's what I'm doing I'm touching them
and that's causing them to fall out I'm
being a bit of a dick
I don't need to do that I do not need to
be dick okay so I can go the washroom
now lamb we are do mad on this toilet of
life we're doomed
doesn't work anymore okay did I just get
hair why did I get here
why was there here oh that's clever oh
that is clever you clever [ __ ] oh that
is very clever
I'm gonna be on my way now because I
have hairs why do I have hairs you want
some hairs it's gross
so why do I need that do I need to add
some flavor to the stew with my hairs no
okay fine then wait that cheese wasn't
there before I got some cheese so now I
can put some cheese right there you'll
do something about that okay back what
what you greedy bastard
gimme whatever you were gonna give me
once more baby sure for you oh you agree
huh oh you want some more cheese huh I
got a whole hunk here you got a hunk of
cheese oh I need it oh I need to put
something on the cheese oh you want
hairs oh okay oh good wait well what
else do you need you greedy bastard what
do you need I give you hair I know I
know I know I know I know I know I get
it I'll get it the poison hi the
poisoned the boys and the poison of
course of course the poison and he's
dead owes a slug
Oh oh good I got in here for it from the
rat slug Oh God
this makes so much sense got do click
where I want you to go hi oh okay fine
nervous how's it going oh shut up and
whatever okay whoa okay
that's weird that worm is oh okay I
didn't know about this okay I was
wandering around for a little bit all
right I might what have we what do I do
about this what is this then there's
something to a point to this why did I
come in here what was the point of this
come on don't be like that baby all the
worms gone oh the worm is gone the worm
was in the beginning
oh hey again how you doing are you the
doctor this small episode is a part of a
bigger game called bad dream coma which
will be releasing oh cool oh he's making
a full-fledged game he she I don't know
what the developer is it's not so cool
oh that's awesome
follow me on Twitter and Facebook if you
hear the lady if you want to hear the
latest news about the game
I would love to all this was so cool
this one was longer and more involved
than the other ones but he was still
just as interesting I mean I had more
wandering around there because I got
lost it wasn't as clear and direct to
the point but that's what happens when
the game becomes more involved but
either way you should also check back
into other drug bed greens games if you
don't know them I
did things that's all for now thank you
for playing oh I want to know more
though I want to know more in it ah damn
it I want to know more damn it
okay be like this was bad dream prison
apparently there's another even bigger
game coming out soon this was awesome I
like this very much go support the
developer in whatever way you can
because if it was gonna be a
full-fledged game that cost money like
it would be worth the money because
these games have been awesome like I
love I love good games overall but it's
often hard to find the nebulous thing of
what is a good game and especially what
is a good horror game this was good in
that it had a mystery and I wanted to
solve it this one was less like less
like grotesque because I've been playing
him in a row obviously the themes that I
understand it becomes less shocking over
time but either way this was really cool
it's an experimental thing I think like
memories was probably the coolest on the
front Cyclops was like bizarre and
interesting and everything flowed really
well but they were all good in each in
their own way so thank you everybody so
much for watching check out the other
bad dream serious games in the playlist
down the description below check out the
other scary games that I played and
there have been a lot of them in the
description as well or in the
annotations over there thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always Oh
in the next video
[Music]